il faut aussi investir dans la recherche et le développement.
A quoi cela pourrait-il ressembler ?
En 1966, les États-Unis ont investi 0,5% de leur PIB
dans le programme Apollo.
Des hommes sont allés sur la Lune
et en sont revenus sains et saufs.
0,5% du PIB actuel est égal à 100 milliards de dollars.
Donc en sachant que la capture du CO2
est un aspect important de la lutte contre le changement climatique,
imaginez que l'on puisse en investir 20%, soit 20 milliards de dollars.
Et imaginons aussi que l'on pourrait diminuer les coûts
pour atteindre 100 dollars par tonne.
Ça sera difficile, mais c'est ce qui rend mon travail amusant.
Mais à quoi ça ressemble
20 milliards de dollars, 100 dollars par tonne ?
Ça nécessite 200 forêts synthétiques,
chacune capable de capturer un million de tonnes de CO2 par an.
Ça diminue les émissions annuelles des États-Unis de 5%.
Ça ne paraît pas énorme.
Mais en réalité, c'est très important.
Si l'on prend les émissions liées au transport routier
et au transport aérien,
ça nous donne 5%.
Notre dépendance sur les carburants liquides rend ces émissions
difficiles à éviter.
Donc cet investissement peut vraiment faire la différence.
Mais quelle superficie faudrait-il pour construire
200 centrales ?
Il faudrait la moitié de la superficie de Vancouver,
et ça seulement si elles fonctionnaient au gaz naturel.
Mais l'inconvénient du gaz naturel, c'est qu'il émet du CO2.
Donc en utilisant du gaz naturel pour capturer le CO2,
on ne capture qu'un tiers de ce que l'on veut
sauf si l'on a la méthode ingénieuse de co-capture
que Carbon Engineering utilise.
Mais si l'on avait une méthode différente
et que l'on utilisait l'énergie solaire ou éolienne,
la superficie serait 15 fois plus grande,
donc à peu près l'État du New Jersey.
Ce que j'essaye de faire dans mon travail et mes recherches
c'est optimisation et trouver où l'on pourrait construire ces centrales,
en prenant en compte les ressources locales,
comme le terrain, l'eau, l'électricité propre et peu coûteuse,
parce que, par exemple, on peut utiliser de l'énergie propre
pour séparer l'hydrogène de l'eau,
qui est une excellente alternative zéro carbone au gaz naturel,
pour fournir la chaleur nécessaire.
Mais revenons aux émissions négatives.
Les émissions négatives ne sont pas la solution miracle,
mais elles peuvent nous aider
si l'on a du mal à réduire les émissions mondiales de CO2.
C'est pourquoi il faut aussi être prudent.
Cette approche est si tentante qu'elle peut être risquée,
car certains peuvent la voir
comme une solution complète à la crise climatique
et peuvent être tentés de continuer à brûler des énergies fossiles
24h sur 24, 7 jours sur 7.
Selon moi, il ne faut pas croire que les émissions négatives
nous dispensent de diminuer la pollution,
mais elles s'ajoutent plutôt à un ensemble de solutions,
comme un meilleur rendement énergétique,
un carbone utilisant peu d'énergie
et une agriculture responsable.
Tout ça nous aidera à atteindre l'objectif zéro émission.
Un peu d'introspection :
mon mari est médecin urgentiste.
Lui et ses collègues sauvent des vies chaque jour,
et ça m'impressionne vraiment.
Mais quand je leur parle de mon travail sur le carbone,
ils sont tout aussi impressionnés,
car combattre le changement climatique en retirant le carbone de l'air
ne sauve pas seulement un ours polaire
ou un glacier,
c'est sauver des vies humaines.
Une forêt synthétique ne sera jamais aussi belle qu'une vraie forêt,
mais elle pourrait nous aider à sauver non seulement l'Amazonie,
mais aussi tous les êtres
qui nous sont chers,
ainsi que les générations futures
et la civilisation moderne.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)